so if you guys got shunted into a
parallel universe and you could save one
time loop time-travel multiverse movie
not your own to be exactly how it is in
this universe which one would it be
wait a movie yeah oh not that all the
other ones go away but this one is gonna
stay the way you love it oh I mean to be
I love Farren I really love it I think I
don't think the world would be better
off if we changed Titanic the world
needs Titanic fare now Li and what would
happen to Leonardo DiCaprio would he
just never get that on with that yeah
was it revenant would that be made ever
hmm
so yeah Titanic save his career yeah so
when you guys got this script what was
and you can say it like in a
non-spoilery way if it's a spoiler we've
seen what was the scene where you're
like I have to do this that's the first
oh hey you're up thank you right
yeah and that that subsequent walk
people have been calling it I guess a
different kind of walk of shame after it
I was like yes I mean also the montage
I'm I've realized through these movies
I'm a big montage girl like love me a
good month and there's so much fun this
this montage on this one is very fun
yeah great job yeah uh what was it like
for you guys you had to reset your
chemistry so much already in the first
film what was it like doing it again
almost the same but just a little bit
different in this one it was really fun
I mean I think one of the things
christos oh well both as a director but
also in the script that he writes is all
of the little nuances are there and so
we weren't just trying to replicate
something that was there before we were
finding it in new in different ways and
I think that's what Trey and Carter are
doing and the film Carter just doesn't
know tree does which is the theme of the
film is Carter just doesn't know but
Carter knows I feel like just with the
whole love triangle when that gets
involved I feel like you really you
really start having a question like
alright is this what is my heart telling
me and what is my head telling me what
is what is my comfort zone saying and
where's my heart being pulled and I
think that's something that Carter has
to struggle with a little bit while
maintaining the aloofness around it all
for tree in this film something I really
love is that you basically pluck a final
girl and put her in another genre what
were the elements of that sort of
archetype that you wanted to bring to
this big sci-fi adventure the most
important thing to me about this film
was making sure that tree remained her
own hero I mean Chris and I had a lot of
conversations about that that like this
is a girl who doesn't run away from the
bad guys she picks up an axe and runs
towards him and that I really want like
even though there are more people
helping her figure things out and she
has to ask for help which I think it's a
hero making thing unto itself like know
when you have to ask for help but I very
protective effect of like she needs to
get herself out of this again because
that's one of the things that I think
audiences responded to so much in the
first film
[Music]